the Joe Rogan experience how it's
amazing yeah crazy video he put on his
YouTube channel
yeah well this is he keeps doing that
character people keep on dying bro right
but how did the guy die suicide was a
suicide it do you see the list after we
see what died what they were involved
with Kevin Spacey's yeah oh my god a lot
yeah there's like three or four accusers
I think I go Majan if it's the actor
from game from house of cards the actor
that was his assistant that killed
people for him imagine that yes
imagine Doug the guy is so deep into his
character that he goes out and whacks
all because it was the best role he had
a god
I see that you think Kevin Spacey get
pissed if we play this yeah you did but
just like max was gonna show up in his
next one I feel like right just that
they're hanging out somewhere but it's
so strange that he's doing it like this
you don't I'm saying this is a character
look he's wrestling the fire I know what
you're thinking it's not that hard
trust me the next time someone does
something you don't like you can go on
the attack but you can also hold your
fire and do the unexpected you can kill
them with kindness
what the [ __ ] he says this and then the
guy commits suicide bro what is this
world
imagine if he threatens everybody and
starts getting jobs again people like I
don't know how he's doing it but
everybody's dying well it's just hiring
man let's house of cards would be
[ __ ] huge just hear me out season
nine we never show that he was dead we
never showed he was dead they that the
last season when they had know him I was
like what are you doing okay what the
[ __ ] are you doing what are you doing
here what would you do to my show to st.
my show this is like oh my god
everybody's watching us that's what the
show was now oh my god everybody's
watching everything we do oh my god now
what do we do
that show seems so like nervous didn't
it the first episode it was like they
didn't have like a regular house of
cards episode it was like everything was
like a little bit barely glued together
like I try to figure out how to say how
he he was gone
or whatever - right and it's like I
wonder if like they were reluctant on
wonderful life escape on the show you
know maybe we'll watch he'll apologize a
refill might they did that other movie
they didn't even start yet right you
remember there was a movie they made
where they had to go back and shoot with
somebody else that he was that's right
yeah that's right done do they never
reshoot it he was great in baby driver
he's a great actor man he's just a crazy
[ __ ] that grabs dicks
the one guy that died though one of the
reasons why I mean I'm not really that I
don't I don't think that this would
warrant a murder all they did was they
were hanging out and he said Kevin
Spacey reached down and grabbed his junk
and said let's go get some air and he
got mad and said no what the [ __ ] but do
you think somewhat mean would that be a
reason why Kevin Spacey would kill you
for saying that I mean how many people
is he gonna kill do you think he killed
people what do you think I want to know
your honest opinion what if he always
killed people
nothing spacey settles assault lawsuit
following death of accuser it was one
week after that video was posted whoa
you settled it how many now I think Sam
Tripoli or somebody posted like a list
of all the people and there was like
four or five people Tripoli might have
yeah
one was loves it Tripoli Xena's glory
and but look this is a real all this
[ __ ] that's happening is a real it's a
good time to be a conspiracy theorist
yeah cuz there's a few of them that
aren't ridiculous there's some juicy
ones right now like [ __ ] this Jack Ruby
[ __ ] let that one go we don't know folks
we're never gonna know but I'll tell you
what we got one in front of us right now
that rivals that we got quite a few of
them
[Applause]